[Music]
[Applause]
m
[Music]
to be a good pointer you don't need a
lot of technique you just need to have
good
technique my highest place is when I
just completely lose thought and there
is no more thinking usually what
inspires me is whether something's going
to beautiful artistic stuff versus
technical stuff the one thing that will
keep this art form continually rising to
share as much as you can those planes
are really only the two-dimensional
boundaries of what's actually going on
in 3D space we put a great deal of
intention into the movements that we
create together I recommend first
envisioning how you want to spin poy and
then figuring out how you need to think
about your PO to achieve achieve that
[Music]
effect
n